[Music]
I'll follow your lead
I don't remember the first time I do I
said very forget a memorable it was a
hell of an entrance because everyone was
silhouetted that day we were just kind
of checking all the silhouettes to see
if he has a very distinct silhouette so
when he kind of came out of the darkness
it was almost as though he planned it
did you know no I didn't I thought it
was my idea actually and then it turned
out that everybody else thought that it
was perfect for Ryan as well but I had
I'd seen him in a couple of films and
wanted to you know admired what he the
work he did and wanted to work with him
and when I read this character I thought
this is perfect that I mentioned it to
them and they said well funny enough
that's who we were thinking of as well
he wanted a percentage of my fee as well
which he took I think the idea of it is
intimidating but I am disappointed it's
over because it is such a great one of
the hardest things to do I think is as
an actor is to to take it seriously but
not take it too seriously and and strike
some kind of balance within that and he
walks that line so effortlessly you
forget there's a line there at all you
know yes such a incredible focus and
intensity of while he's working that
it's it's really uh it's the perfect
balance and you know you just wish it
could kind of be like that all the time
how do you like to be complimented as
that I think you're doing a great okay
exactly the same thing about you
well I was gonna spin it out a little
bit right but try and make it sound like
I really meant it no no no yeah his
palatial dressing room I know I didn't
think I didn't think there was any
contest yeah there was never a moment or
a Harrison was like it was numbered a
good way with my friend stop oh you want
to come
no never asked me to go well on my pegs
no no thank you for that thank you
you know was a it's a physically
demanding movie we both the cooperating
promote plane crash he'd I don't know
what happened to him I good excuse but
you know we were both trying to keep
fish for the whatever demands the movie
might place on us I was
gatir no you didn't have the styles for
[Laughter]
there's nothing good about being our
contract yeah there was nothing good at
all I had to do whatever they required
you to do and there was no you had no
choice I didn't at least I was under
contract to Columbia and then under
contract to Universal for a short period
of time and it was a nightmare
[Laughter]
[Music]
it just kind of goes in one yeah I would
be very suspicious of anybody that had
advice let me tell you something do this
or do that it's kind of obscure things
are sometimes useful Mike Nichols said
don't let them turn you into a thing
that was a good advice I have no idea
what it means but I thought it was a
really good advice
didn't you have a stage name at one
point uh there was a Harrison Ford when
I went to sign up for the Screen Actors
Guild I got the first three jobs you
know you can do three jobs without
hurting you
member of the screen at your school when
I went to the Screen Actors Guild and
they've said during signing this photo
and they said we can't be Harrison Ford
and so we're not safe because there is a
Harrison Ford Gilardi and turned out he
was 93 years old he was a silent screen
star and they said what do you want to
be called
I said Harrison J Ford and I was
Harrison J for the ceiling but is that
what you're thinking
no no Curt affair that's me but that was
a the studio wanted me to change my name
right and I came back gonna settle came
running after Kurt
[Music]